hey guys it's just stayed and today we
have the new Samsung 8kq LED TV this is
the 82 inch version we saw this at CES
this year and it was absolutely amazing
and guess what he's here and we're about
to unbox it side note it's really heavy
can we just
this doesn't even span the length of my
arms let's unbox this is so huge and
this isn't even the biggest versions
they have the biggest version is a 98
inch model they also have a 65 75 and an
85 and this is somewhere sort of in the
middle this is the 82 it I hope that the
TV stand that I got is big enough you
guys know how I am with measuring I'm
also really excited to try this because
it has something called 8k AI upscaling
now I don't shoot my content in a just
yet but with the 8k AI upscaling
it ensures that my content looks amazing
even if it isn't 8k I'm gonna let this
go and it's gonna just be like a big
reveal there's a lot of stuff going on
let me let me resort back to my manual
oh these are the legs all right I'm
gonna get these legs on this thing and
then we're gonna set it up on the TV
stand and get it all set up
[Music]
I wish that all of you guys were here
right now in this room wouldn't you see
what I'm witnessing right now one of the
things that I've noticed already is
normally sitting on the floor at this
angle with any other television you
would not be able to get a clear view of
the TV because viewing angles can be so
finicky but with this it has an ultra
viewing angle so basically anywhere that
you are in the room you're gonna have a
really great view of the TV so here's
ambient mode this is kind of cool
because usually if your screen is off
it'll just be a black screen which is
kind of boring but this has all kinds of
really cool things you can add things
like the weather or the time or latest
news headlines listen I feel like I'm in
the tub right now these look so good any
time I'm done editing a video I love to
see what it looks like on a television
and now this is so easy to do because
with airplay - all I have to do is I can
export my video and then I'm just gonna
share it using airplay - and like magic
it's on your TV airplay to support isn't
just in this TV it is available as a
firmware upgrade - 2018 Samsung Smart
TVs and it's kind of crazy because this
is available in 190 countries worldwide
it is the first to have the Apple TV app
integrated into the TV platform no
external hardware is needed and the new
app brings over a hundred thousand
movies and TV shows and you can
subscribe to premium channels like HBO
and Showtime and you can even airplay
music I have an incredible royalty-free
track here prepared just for you
[Music]
you can also show YouTube videos much
like this video from CES where I'm
actually looking at this TV in Vegas use
AI in upscale content so content that is
not ready break a television did you
hear what Justine several months ago
just said she was talking wait i'm she
me i i was talking about the AI
upscaling which is something that is
really fascinating to me because I don't
yet shoot an 8k it's a little
automatically be upscaled to look
incredible on this television and one of
the great things about this TV that I
may have mentioned before is the ultra
viewing angle is incredible so you can
be anywhere in the room I still have a
perfect view of the screen we've been
talking a lot about 8k content so let's
view some 8k content
everything is so crystal clear and
lifelike that's sitting in front of this
TV it's like looking out an open window
into the world it really is overwhelming
how amazing this picture quality looks
in person
there's another really cool thing called
ambient mode so this is the ambient mode
button so when you press that it brings
you into this little selection here and
it'll just display different types of
content so you can also sync this up to
play your own photos as well you can
look at New York Times headlines here
you can check the weather 71 and sunny
in my current location and it's really
cool because you can also have we done
talking yet cuz I'd like to play some
games actually speaking of games this
just reminded me of something so there's
this really cool feature called real
game enhancer and it uses variable
refresh technology motion blur reduction
and what I'm most excited about is this
auto game mode it helps minimize the
input lag so if you have a controller
and you're trying to play a first-person
shooter game like that little bit of
input lag makes me go good scrap out
just you'll be over here it makes me
crazy it can definitely affect your
gameplay and you guys know it or maybe
it's because you're actually not very
good and you need someone else to blame
ah I think I'm done with you now no no
no don't turn me down no no are you
still talking can you hear me any filly
of me I think we're we're done with her
let's play some rocket League oh my god
this is so fast I can't even find the
ball wait what color am i what what are
we going in that hole
I scored a champion sign me up for
whatever I need a sign up for and I'm
just that incredible somebody say
somebody are you mom are you my friend
Joe Joe no come on guys rift go I'm
gonna get so into this game anyway I
could play this all day long but I swear
- thank you guys so much for watching I
would love to hear what you guys think
of its TV and I cannot wait to watch
more content on this again a huge thank
you to Samsung for sponsoring this video
you guys are amazing
and I look forward to continuing to play
this game so I'll see you guys later
rocket League let's go